Mona Vetsch - auf nichts vorbereitet,
aber auf alles gefasst.
Drei Tage im Schweizerischen
Paraplegiker-Zentrum Nottwil.
Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
Passt.
- Gut, dann schauen wir mal.
Wir gehen in den Znüniraum.
Dort stelle ich dir
einen Teil des Teams vor.
Zu ihnen gehört auch Till.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Das ist Till.
- Hoi, Till.
Du führst mich heute ...
- Genau. - Super.
(Schon im Gang
bleiben Till und ich hängen.)
(Ein Patient verabschiedet sich.)
Dürfen wir rasch auf euch zukommen?
Ich bin Mona.
- Michael, tschau.
Mona, freut mich.
Heute ist dein letzter Tag hier?
- Ja.
Okay.
Es ist ein grosses Gefühl:
Ich darf nach Hause.
Wow!
- Ohne Seich.
Wie lange warst du hier?
Am 17. Juni bin ich
vom Inselspital hergekommen.
Also d.h., du bist mehr
als ein halbes Jahr hier gewesen.
Knapp neun Monate.
Sie haben mich geflickt.
Ich kann wieder reden.
Ich kann den Arm wieder brauchen.
Es ist wirklich cool.
D.h., das konntest du vorher
alles nicht?
Bist du die Freundin?
- Ja.
Entschuldige,
weil ich da einfach ...
Hattest du einen Unfall?
- Mit dem Jeep.
Es hat mich im Gelände überschlagen.
Blöd eigentlich.
Also ein Autounfall.
Ich wollte einem Reh ausweichen.
Es überschlug mich und dann hat es
mich aus dem Wagen geschleudert.
14 Tage später
erwachte ich im Spital
und wusste nicht, wie mir geschah.
Der Stecker wurde dreimal gezogen,
aber ich hatte mich geweigert.
Beim vierten Mal erwachte ich.
Das habe ich richtig verstanden? Die
Maschinen sollten abgestellt werden?
Ja, dreimal.
- Nein! Ehrlich?
Das ist ja
eine unglaubliche Geschichte.
Es ist gut.
Wie habt ihr das
zusammen hingekriegt?
Sie ist jeden Tag
die Hauptverantwortliche.
Sie fährt täglich von Habkern her,
208 km.
Das ist die Arbeit vom ganzen Haus,
vom ganzen Team.
Aber er sagt, du seist es.
- Ich war einfach da.
Jeden Tag.
- Mhm.
Jeden?  - Ja.
- Jeden.
Sie kam jeden Tag?
- Ja.
Cool.
Hey, wow!
Jetzt gehen wir wieder nach Hause.
Viele würden sagen, im Rollstuhl
zu sitzen, sei ein Riesenunglück.
Ach!
Ich war keinen Tag böse,
keinen Tag betrübt,
weil ich im Rollstuhl bin.
Ich hatte riesiges Glück,
dass ich überhaupt noch lebe.
Vielen Dank, dass wir euch
einfach so fragen durften.
Gern geschehen.
Toi, toi, toi!
- Vielen Dank.
Geniesst den Moment. Alles Gute!
- Merci.
Eine gute Zeit zusammen.
* Sanfte, emotionale Klaviermusik *
Das sind die schönen Geschichten,
wirklich.
Sehr schön zu sehen ...
Er sagte selbst, wo er vor neun
Monaten stand und wo er jetzt ist.
Das ist ... Das tut mega gut.
(Viele Patienten kommen in Nottwil
zuerst auf die Intensivstation.)
(Gelähmt, in ein Leben geworfen,
welches sie nicht selbst wählten.)
(In der Reha werden sie bestmöglich
auf ihr neues Leben vorbereitet.)
(Dafür macht man in Nottwil alles:)
(Physiotherapie ...
... Sport ...
... und eine eigene Abteilung,
in welcher der Rollstuhl
an die Bedürfnisse
jedes einzelnen angepasst wird.)
(Jeder Patient
hat seine eigene Geschichte.)
(Jene von Jürg
lerne ich jetzt kennen.)
Er ist auch querschnittgelähmt
und ähm ...
Du kannst mit ihm ein bisschen ...
Er weiss, dass ich komme?
- Ja, er weiss, dass du kommst.
Hoi, ich bin Mona.
- Jürg, freut mich.
Hoi, Jürg.
- Mona-Visite.
Du hast einen ähnlichen Dialekt.
Wir kommen aus der ähnlichen Region.
Du, aber ...
Er hat gesagt,
du seist querschnittgelähmt.
Du sitzt da wie ein junges Reh.
Ich stehe zur Begrüssung nicht auf,
aber sitzen geht, ja.
Aber auch nicht seit immer.
Also, oder ...
- Ja, also ...
Ich habe
eine inkomplette Paraplegie.
Das heisst, ähm ...
Ich hatte gewisse Funktionen
noch von Anfang an.
Ich kann zum Glück
meine Beine noch etwas bewegen.
Ich habe Stöcke und Schienen.
Ich bin daran, mich möglichst
aus dem Rollstuhl herauszuarbeiten.
Ja.
Bist du gelähmt?
Bist du ... oder was ist das?
Das ist eine gute Frage,
ich überlege manchmal auch,
was ich sagen soll,
wenn ich gefragt werde.
Ich sage, ich hätte ein Manko.
- Ja. Was ist bei dir passiert?
Bei mir war es so:
Ich war mit dem Gleitschirm
auf einem Streckenflug.
Und ich bin
unsanft zu Boden gekommen.
Ab dem Moment weiss ich
eigentlich nichts mehr.
Ich konnte danach zum Glück
selbst die REGA alarmieren.
Obwohl du nichts mehr weisst?
Meine letzte Erinnerung ist,
dass ich den Notschirm gezogen habe.
Dann weiss ich einfach wieder,
dass ich zu mir gekommen bin.
Die Erinnerung
setzt dort wieder ein,
wo ich zum Handy gegriffen
und aus einem Reflex heraus
die REGA alarmiert habe.
Ja.
Dann denkt man sich schon:
"War's das jetzt?"
Ein Leben im Rollstuhl.
Das, was man ...
Die Bilder, die man im Kopf hat.
- ... nie wollte.
Und jetzt hat es mich erwischt.
Wenn man das so spürt ...
... das ist heftig.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
(Jürg ist 38, verheiratet
und Vater von drei Kindern.)
(Von Beruf ist er Geotechniker.)
(Bewegung war immer
ein wichtiger Teil seines Lebens.)
(Als er vor fünf Monaten
hier angekommen ist,
konnte er nicht einmal
seine Füsse bewegen.)
(Jetzt lernt er wieder laufen, auch
mithilfe dieses Gerätes, dem Ekso.)
Mona.
- Renzo.
Jürg.
- Hoi.
Fangen wir an. Ich habe eine neue
Assistentin. Du kannst mitmachen.
Du musst den Schraubenzieher
da hineinstecken und drehen.
Wann hast du das Ding
zum ersten Mal gesehen?
Das war vor etwa zwei Monaten.
(Renzo) Heute ist es das 16. Mal.
Und? Was hast du gedacht?
Am Anfang sieht es natürlich
recht abschreckend aus,
so robotermässig.
Man liefert sich dem aus.
Ich habe mich recht schnell
mit ihm angefreundet,
ich konnte mit ihm
zum ersten Mal wieder laufen.
Meine ersten Schritte
habe ich damit gemacht.
Das Gefühl, wieder einmal ein Bein
vor das andere zu setzen, war ...
... obwohl es technisch
und robotermässig war ...
Entschuldigung.
- Schon gut.
Es war ein schönes Gefühl,
wieder einmal zu laufen.
Du bist nur zur Sicherheit da, bist
aber immer dran. - Ich halte es.
* Piepsen *
Okay, Gewicht links.
Und Schritt rechts.
Du läufst einfach mit.
- Ja.
(Renzo) Du begleitest ihn.
Schön sachte dranbleiben.
(Renzo) Aufpassen, dass deine Füsse
nicht unter seine geraten.
Nach vorne schauen.
* Ruhige Musik,
sanftes Motorengeräusch *
Jürg, ist das anstrengend?
Ja, es der Widerstand
ist schon recht gross.
Geh mal vor ihn!
- Ja.
Schau mal, wie er läuft.
Hat es Auffälligkeiten?
Das sieht super aus!
- (Renzo) Geht's, Jürg?
Es geht, ja.
Lauft er schön?
- Ja, sehr schön.
Okay, wir machen mal eine Pause.
Gut, Jürg.
Hat man dir gleich gesagt,
dass es möglich sein kann
oder hast du dich selbst
an der Hoffnung festgehalten?
Ich glaube, Hoffnung schadet nie.
Hoffnung bedeutet ja nicht Prognose.
Hoffnung ist wirklich ...
Ich habe einfach das Gefühl,
sie bringt dich mental
im ganzen Prozess weiter.
Auch wenn es nicht eintritt,
hat es einen positiven Effekt.
Und, ja, ich finde ...
Hoffnung ist etwas vom Wichtigsten.
(Wieder laufen zu können,
eigenständig zu sein,
dass sich die verletzten Nerven
wieder erholen.)
(Das ist der Traum eines jeden,
der hier ist.)
(Lange nicht für alle wird er wahr.)
(Die Verletzung setzt Grenzen,
die jeder akzeptieren muss.)
(Trotzdem ist jeder
noch so kleine Erfolg
ein wichtiger Schritt zurück
zu mehr Selbstständigkeit.)
Da hat es zwei Personen,
die auf dich warten.
Auf mich?
- Genau.
Meine Kollegin Suse und Melanie.
Hallo.
- Susanne Brunner.
Freut mich. Ich komme zu dir.
Mona.
- Meli.
Freut mich.
Wie lange bist du schon hier?
- Seit achteinhalb Monaten.
Aber du gehst bald?
- In zweieinhalb Wochen.
Ich stehe so blöd rum.
Kann man irgendwo sitzen?
Auf einem Stuhl oder auf der Bank.
Du liegst da -
ich habe keine Ahnung.
Du bist da,
d.h., du hast irgendeine Lähmung.
Genau, ich hatte vor achteinhalb
Monaten eine Halswirbelverletzung.
Da oben?
- Am sechsten, siebten Halswirbel.
Und was heisst das körperlich
nun für dich?
D.h., ähm ...
Ich bin Tetraplegikerin.
Arme und Beine sind involviert.
Ja.
- Genau.
Die Arme kannst du bewegen?
Ja, aber ich kann die Hände
nicht mehr normal brauchen.
Diese kann ich wieder schliessen
und diese eher nur öffnen.
Das musste ich wieder lernen.
Das ging alles nicht.
Was hattest du für einen Unfall?
- Vom Pferd gestürzt.
Diese Horrorvorstellung, dass man
vom Pferd fällt und dann ...
Dann ist es einfach anders gegangen
als die anderen Male.
Sehr gut.
Was spürst du, wenn ich das mache?
Ich nehme es im Beckenbereich
ein wenig wahr.
Das hat sich auch
erst wieder entwickelt.
Das war am Anfang nicht.
Am Anfang war einfach nichts.
- Ja, ab hier.
Man kann sich nicht vorstellen,
wie das ist, nichts zu spüren.
Es ist ähnlich, wie wenn man
beim Zahnarzt eine Spritze bekommt.
Hier habe ich z.T.
etwas Hautsensibilität,
aber keine Schmerzen,
keine Kälte, keine Wärme.
Wenn die Spritze vom Zahnarzt
aufwacht und du in die Backe beisst,
merkt man es,
aber es schmerzt nicht.
So ist es vorstellbar. So empfinde
ich auch an den Unterarmen.
Ich spüre zwar keine Schmerzen mehr,
aber durchaus Berührungen.
(Susanne)
Was Melanie neu üben musste:
Wie dreht man sich,
ohne dass man Rumpf und Beine
selbst steuern kann?
Das hat relativ
entspannt ausgesehen.
Wie lange dauerte es,
bis du das konntest?
Wie lange übten wir? Einige Monate.
- (Susanne) Ja.
Bis man das Gefühl dafür hat.
Als du nach dem Reitunfall
hierhergekommen bist ...
Warst du ganz anders,
als wie ich dich jetzt sehe?
Ich lag da und konnte den Kopf
2 cm nach rechts und links bewegen,
den rechten Arm ein bisschen.
Sonst konnte ich nichts bewegen.
Die Hände nicht, den linken Arm
nicht. - Boah!
Das ist erst im Laufe der Zeit
wieder gekommen.
Es war also schon
relativ vieles anders.
Du lagst da und konntest
mit den Augen noch so machen.
Das war alles.
- Ja.
In deiner Welt.
- Genau.
(Ich solle später zu ihr ins Zimmer
kommen, sagte Melanie.)
(Dann hätten wir Zeit zum Reden.)
Das ist schon ein Erfolgserlebnis,
das mit den Händen machen zu können.
Das war alles Übungssache.
- Ja.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
(Gegen Abend wird es ruhig
im Paraplegiker-Zentrum.)
(Die Therapiestunden sind um, die
Menschen wieder mit sich alleine.)
(Es sind die Stunden, in welchen man
Zeit zum Nachdenken hat.)
(So viele hier hätten Grund
zum Verzweifeln.)
(Aber was ich erlebe, sind Menschen,
die vorwärtsschauen,
die Hoffnung haben
und für ihre Zukunft kämpfen.)
(Jürg hat Besuch von seiner Frau
Andrea und seinen drei Kindern.)
(Sie verbringen die Schulferien
in Nottwil.)
(So können sie als Familie
möglichst nahe beieinander sein.)
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
(Ich mache mich
auf den Weg zu Melanie.)
(Einer jungen Frau, die mit 26
ihren eigenen Reiterhof pachtet
und sich damit einen Lebenstraum
verwirklicht hat.)
Gefunden.
- Genau.
Hoi, Melanie.
- Hoi, Mona.
Müde? Oder geht's?
- Schon etwas müde, aber es geht.
Wo bist du?
Ich bin z.B. da unten,
ganz rechts unten. Genau.
Wann war das?
Etwa anfangs September 2016.
Wenn ich sie anschaue,
also dich anschaue ...
Wie warst du?
Wie hättest du dich beschrieben?
Wie hätte ich mich beschrieben?
Ich glaube, ich war
ein sehr fröhlicher Mensch.
Das ist jetzt
manchmal etwas schwierig.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
ich bin jetzt eher
etwas schwieriger geworden,
weil vieles nicht mehr so geht.
Früher sagte ich: "Wenn du etwas
willst, kannst du alles machen."
"Du musst es genügend wollen,
gewisse Kompromisse eingehen
und bereit dazu sein."
Das hat mich immer
sehr mutig gemacht.
Sehr mutig und eigentlich
auch sehr glücklich,
weil ich die Ziele
auch erreichen konnte.
Schmerzt dich das, wenn du siehst,
wie dein Leben
vorher ausgesehen hat?
Oder ist das ...?
Ja, schmerzt es?
Diese Fotowand war in dieser Reha
beides für mich.
Einerseits hat sie mir
wahnsinnig viel bedeutet,
weil sie mir Kraft gegeben hat.
Die meisten von ihnen gehören
zu meinem engsten Umfeld,
die mir viel bedeuten, die oft bei
mir waren und mich unterstützten.
Wenn du immer wieder siehst,
dass Leute hinter dir stehen,
die das mit dir mitmachen
und die auf dich warten,
die daran glauben, dass es eine
Lösung gibt, gibt einem das Kraft.
Gleichzeitig schmerzt es aber auch.
Wenn ich mich an einen Tag erinnere
oder an einen Moment,
den ich mit den Menschen und Pferden
verbracht habe, dann schmerzt es.
Dann ist Wehmut dabei
und es ist schwer.
* Nachdenkliche Klaviermusik *
(Melanie möchte zurück auf den Hof
und den Betrieb weiterführen.)
(Auch wenn sie selbst
nie mehr Pferde bereiten kann.)
* Nachdenkliche Klaviermusik *
(In den letzten Monaten
haben Melanie und Jürg
oft im geschützten Umfeld des
Paraplegiker-Zentrums trainiert.)
(Heute geht es mit einer Gruppe hin-
aus ins Stadttraining, nach Luzern.)
(Raus ins reale Leben, wo sie sich
bald wieder zurechtfinden müssen.)
(Jürg) Eine Herausforderung
für mich wird sein,
wie weit ich überhaupt komme.
Wie sieht es mit der Ermüdung aus?
Ist ein Nachmittag in der Stadt
nicht zu anstrengend?
Das Rollstuhlfahren ...
Ich bringe noch viel Gewicht
auf die Stöcke.
Ich balanciere alles
mit den Stöcken aus.
Ich kann nicht ohne Stöcke
frei dastehen.
Wie geht das
mit den Rolltreppenübergängen?
Wie geht es auf die Rolltruppe
und v.a. von der Rolltreppe
wieder runter?
Ich muss die Griffe loslassen.
Das stelle ich mir
noch anspruchsvoll vor.
Ja. Funktioniert das überhaupt?
Das werden wir sehen.
(Melanie im Rollstuhl,
Jürg an Krücken.)
(Als Erstes müssen sie lernen,
Rolltreppen zu fahren.)
Mit dem Rollstuhl
wäre ich schneller.
Ja. Aber dir
geht es gerade nicht darum, oder?
Nein, im Moment nicht.
Erst müssen wir mein Ding loswerden.
Was meinst du?
- Geht das mit dem auch?
Das glaube ich nicht. Aber ohne das.
Okay, Laurent,
wenn du gleich mit Yves machst?
Melanie?
Ich kann mich nicht halten.
Genau.
Sie hält sich gar nicht.
- Nein, sie hält sich gar nicht.
(Weil Melanie mit ihren Händen
nicht greifen kann,
hat sie
ihren eigenen Weg entwickelt.)
(Sie lehnt sich weit nach vorne und
kann mit dem Gewicht des Oberkörpers
den Rollstuhl auf der Treppe halten.
Das erstaunt sogar die Therapeuten.)
Wie ist es gelaufen?
- Gut.
Es braucht Beweglichkeit,
damit ich vorne bleibe.
Ich kann mich nicht halten.
Eben. Du kannst nicht ...
Ich kann mich
mit den Händen nicht halten.
Ich muss mein ganzes Gewicht
nach vorne beugen.
Es sieht ziemlich kamikazehaft aus,
wenn ich das so sagen darf.
Wir haben es schon mal gemacht, aber
nicht gewusst, ob es funktioniert.
Man sollte sich ja halten.
- Eben, ja.
(Jürg versucht es zum ersten Mal
mit den Krücken.)
Nehme ich ihn jetzt schon
in die Hand?
So.
Wie fühlst du dich wohler?
Eine Hand an der ...
Nein, der Übergang geht besser,
wenn ich eine Hand bereits dort habe
und dann den Stock nehme.
Ja, gut.
Soll ich vor oder hinter dir sein?
- Vielleicht neben mir.
(Noch hat er die Unterstützung
des Therapeuten, Carsten.)
Mit der Schiene ist es ungewohnt.
Hier ist es ...
Gut, okay.
- Tipptopp.
Es lief gut, oder?
- Ja.
Es geht, wenn ich beide Stöcke
in die Hand nehmen kann.
Mich halten und gleichzeitig
den Stock nehmen, ist schwierig.
Wenn ich die Rolltreppe
eher loslassen kann, geht es.
Wieder ein kleines Hindernis
weniger? - Ja, genau.
Es ist speziell,
wenn man euch als Gruppe sieht.
Ja, man fällt natürlich auf.
- Total.
Man fühlt sich auch ...
Ich weiss nicht, wie es dir geht,
aber ich fühle mich
in der Gruppe "behinderter",
als wenn ich selbstständig allein
durch den Bahnhof flitze.
Jetzt schauen natürlich alle:
"Oh, aha."
"Ausflug des Paraplegiker-Zentrums".
Plötzlich gehörst du dazu.
Das ist schon ...
Da hast du recht.
- Vorher gehört man nicht dazu.
Das ist manchmal das,
was mir zu schaffen macht:
zu akzeptieren,
dass ich nun auch dazu gehöre.
(Jürg will nach fünf Monaten Nottwil
als Fussgänger zurück ins Leben.)
(Für dieses Ziel macht er alles.)
* Sanft-melancholische Musik *
(Melanie will so selbstständig
wie möglich zurück auf ihren Hof.)
Ich bin eben langsamer.
(Therapeutin) Hochstossen!
Ich kann nicht.
In dem Moment, wo es rüttelt ...
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
(Therapeutin) Jawohl!
- Yes!
Zusätzlich, dass man nicht mehr
gehen oder nichts mehr bewegen kann,
keine Hände hat,
die man brauchen kann ...
Dass die Hände nicht mehr mitmachen,
ist fast am schlimmsten.
Der Spaziergang
über die Kapellbrücke war wie ...
... eine kleine Feier für mich.
Auch wenn es ein kurzes Stück war -
das hat mir nun gerade
sehr viel bedeutet.
Man beginnt,
die Welt anders zu betrachten.
Man fragt sich im Vergleich zu
vorher, was wirkliche Probleme sind.
Wenn sich die Leute
über etwas ärgern,
denke ich schon oft: "Deine Probleme
möchte ich auch haben."
(In zwei Wochen
werden Melanie und Jürg
aus der
Rehabilitation entlassen.)
(Dann gehen sie zurück
in ihr altes Leben,
das aber ein neues sein wird.
Auch für ihre Familien.)
Wie war das für dich,
den Papa so lange nicht
zu Hause gehabt zu haben?
Am Anfang war es schlimmer.
Jetzt ist es schon fast normal.
Fast schon normal?
Wie ist es, ihn hier zu besuchen?
Ja, cool.
- Cool?
Hast du gesehen,
dass Papa gehen kann?
Wie findest du das?
Du hast von Anfang an gesagt,
dass ich wieder gehen werde.
Sicher?
- Ja, sie sagte von Anfang an:
"Weisst du, Papa,
du wirst wieder gehen."
Echt?
- Ja.
Nicht wahr?
Du hast fest an mich geglaubt.
Was hat das
mit eurer Beziehung gemacht?
Mit euch und eurer Familie?
Ich finde, es hat uns nähergebracht.
Als wir in der Nacht damals auf
den Bescheid der OP gewartet haben,
spürte ich ...
Ich wollte die Kinder
aus der Schule nehmen
und für immer nach Nottwil gehen.
Ich fand, wir müssen zusammen sein.
- Während der Reha.
Genau.
Es hat uns zusammengeschweisst.
Wir hatten viel Zeit zusammen.
Das hast du auch gesagt:
dass du mehr Familienzeit hattest,
als wenn du das letzte halbe Jahr
gearbeitet hättest.
Wenn jemand im Rollstuhl
oder sogar noch pflegebedürftig ist
und weiss, dass die Partnerin
einen ein Leben lang pflegen muss,
ist das ...
Es ist schwierig, das zu ertragen.
Dass man in der Beziehung
damit klarkommt,
ohne dabei Schuldgefühle
zu entwickeln.
Auch wenn man keine Schuld trägt.
Das belastet sicher.
Man ist dann nicht mehr ...
auf Augenhöhe.
Wovor habt ihr beide Respekt
oder gar etwas Angst?
Ich habe Respekt vor ...
... deinem Gemütszustand.
V.a. wenn er zu Hause ist.
Hier in der Klinik ...
... zählt man in deinem Zustand
zu den Gesunden.
Es ist alles ebenerdig,
rollstuhlgängig.
Das ganze Umfeld ist eingerichtet.
Zu Hause schrumpft diese Welt
stark zusammen.
Im Winter gibt es Schnee,
unsere Zufahrtsstrasse
ist nicht rollstuhlgängig.
Das sind solche Dinge.
Zu Hause ... ist man ständig
von Fussgängern umgeben.
Freunde ...
- Genau.
Frühling, Flugwetter, Bikewetter ...
Ja.
Mit Freunden, mit der Familie,
in der Verwandtschaft
ist man plötzlich derjenige,
der das schwächste Glied
in der Kette darstellt,
v.a. wenn man unterwegs ist.
Das wird dann noch einmal
eine neue Situation.
Was darf man euch
für die Zukunft wünschen?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich wünsche mir, dass wir
mit der Situation, die am Ende ist,
umgehen können.
Und das Beste rausholen
und das Schöne sehen können.
Wir möchten auch weiterhin die Augen
für die schönen Momente offenhaben,
die das Leben
noch für uns bereithält.
* Melancholische Musik *
(Und hier ist sie wieder:
die Hoffnung.)
(Die Hoffnung und der positive Blick
in die Zukunft,
die Jürg und Melanie
aufrechterhält.)
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
(Frühmorgens.)
(Mir geht viel durch den Kopf.)
(Aufstehen, anziehen, Zähne putzen -
all das nehme ich
als selbstverständlich hin.)
(Aber von einer Sekunde auf
die nächste kann das Leben drehen.)
(So vieles,
worüber man nicht nachdachte,
wird zum fast unüberwindbaren
Hindernis.)
(Melanie und Jürg dürfen
über das Wochenende nach Hause.)
(Vorher steht für Jürg
ein wichtiger Test an,
der darüber entscheidet,
ob er zukünftig Auto fahren darf.)
Was hast du für einen Termin?
- Motorisierungsabklärung.
Ich hatte das schon vor drei Wochen.
Man muss mit dem Bein 50 kg
drücken können.
Die Bremskraft.
- Ich schaffte nur 48 kg.
Darum wollten wir es in zwei Wochen
noch einmal versuchen.
Ich war im Kraftraum.
Ist das für deine Freiheit wichtig,
dass du ...
Ja, v.a. zu Beginn.
Gerade auch im Hinblick
auf meinen Beruf.
Auf die Berufstätigkeit.
Sonst müsste man dort
das Auto auch noch umbauen.
Das macht alles kompliziert.
Wenn wir sagen, die erste Stufe ist,
dass ich mit einem Automat
fahren kann, ist das gut.
Optimal wäre natürlich,
wenn ich auch ein manuelles Auto
wieder fahren könnte.
Aber das könnte man auch erst
in zwei bis drei Monaten testen.
Ja.
Viel Erfolg.
- Viel Erfolg. - Danke.
(Mind. 50 kg muss Jürg
auf das Bremspedal bringen.)
Also. Brauchst du
ein Rutschbrett für den Transfer?
Nein, es geht.
Hast du noch Wertsachen drin?
- Nein.
Den Stuhl lassen wir hier.
(Melanie wird für das Wochenende
von ihrer Schwester Debbie abgeholt,
die neben ihrem eigenen Job auch
Melanies Reiterhof weiterführte.)
Debbie, was denkst du?
Geht deine Schwester wieder zurück
in ihr altes Leben
oder wird das ein völlig
neues Leben, das jetzt beginnt?
Ein Stück weit
wird es ihr altes Leben sein.
Das mit den Pferden und dem Hof
war schon immer ihr Lebenstraum.
Soweit sie das kann,
möchte sie das weiterführen.
Mich interessiert:
Feiert man ein Fest?
Oder feiert man das sonst
auf eine Art?
Es gibt welche, die ihren Unfalltag
als zweiten Geburtstag feiern,
weil sie überlebt haben.
Feiern,
dass man wieder nach Hause kommt?
Aber es ist nicht so,
wie ich es gerne gehabt hätte.
Freud und Leid ist nah beieinander.
Ich freue mich
auf das Nachhausekommen,
meine Freunde und Tiere
um mich zu haben.
Andererseits wäre ich gerne
anders nach Hause gekommen.
Das ist ...
... ein gemischtes Gefühl.
Also, Jürg.
Ich muss dich etwas plagen.
Dort vorne ist eine 50er-Tafel.
Du beschleunigst auf 50.
Irgendwann drücke ich diesen Knopf.
Dann lacht dich diese Lampe rot an.
Ich möchte,
dass du eine Vollbremsung machst,
ich beobachte deine Reaktionszeit.
Ziel ist,
dass das ABS ausgelöst wird.
Und dass wir ...
- ... anhalten.
Ich achte auf den Verkehr,
du auf die rote Lampe.
Super! Perfekt.
- Ist das gut?
Hat die Reaktionszeit gepasst?
- Einwandfrei. Ja.
Ich dachte nicht,
dass ich über 60 komme.
Aber der Sportlehrer hat getippt,
dass ich über 63 schaffe.
Wir haben
um einen Schokoriegel gewettet.
Was hast du gesagt? 64?
- 64.
Jetzt schulde ich ihm eines.
- Das magst du verkraften.
(64 kg Bremsdruck,
ein grosser Erfolg
und ein wichtiger Schritt zurück
ins Leben draussen.)
Hallo.
- Hey! Dürfen wir das Auto behalten?
Ja, dürfen wir.
- Juhu!
Cool.
- Es hat geklappt.
Bravo.
- Danke, Mathis.
Wer bekommt den Schokoriegel?
- Ich schulde Carsten einen.
(Melanie und Jürg haben
einen anstrengenden Weg vor sich,
wenn sie in zwei Wochen
Nottwil verlassen.)
(Aber sie sind schon weit gekommen
in den Monaten
seit dem schweren Schicksalsschlag.)
(Dank viel Willen, Hoffnung
und Menschen, die bei ihnen sind.)
Nachher kommt er ganz nach Hause.
- Wer?
Papi.
Schönes Wochenende.
- Schönes Wochenende.
Vielen Dank.
- Danke dir.
Es waren extrem spannende drei Tage.
Euch alles Gute, für eure Arbeit.
- Vielen Dank.
Ein gutes Wochenende.
(Drei Tage im Paraplegiker-Zentrum.)
(Auch ich komme anders raus
als ich reingegangen bin.)
(Dankbar für so vieles,
was vorher selbstverständlich war.)
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
A. Werlen, S. Näpflin - 2019